[Música]
quem aqui levanta a mão pra mim quem é
que se sente hoje realizado tanto na sua
vida pessoal quanto na sua vida
profissional minoria como eu previa isso
acontece em vários outros lugares
a realização ela é com um processo então
em tese do dia que a gente nasce até o
dia que a gente vive
a gente está em processo de realização e
cal rogers é o psicólogo fundador da
psicologia humanista ele disse que nós
todos nascemos com uma tendência natural
que vai nos guiar para essa realização
para o desenvolvimento do nosso máximo
potencial e é a percepção de estarmos
nesse caminho que vai dar pra gente a
sensação de felicidade mas hoje porque
será que a minoria se sente nesse
caminho
a gente está vivendo uma era
hoje que a depressão ela está ocupando o
terceiro lugar dos maiores transtornos
emocionais e também tem a ansiedade a
gente nunca viu
nunca vivemos néné nós nunca vivemos uma
era com tanta gente depressiva e ansiosa
e ansiosa nem basta a gente olhar para o
nosso lado que a gente vai perceber isso
então onde equipar o nosso equívoco em
que será que está acontecendo pra gente
ter se perdido daquele caminho que o
rocha disse que seria natural e chegamos
aqui bem o que eu vim falar com vocês
aqui hoje é que a educação interfere no
processo de realização já parou pra
pensar aqui é muito curioso o fato de a
gente está vivendo uma era de pessoas
infelizes não foi exatamente com os
nossos pais sonharam pra gente né
o que se tem um sonho que é unanimidade
entre todo pai e mãe é o que é que o seu
filho seja feliz e não é isso que está
acontecendo
o que acontece é que ao longo da nossa
existência
a gente não tem mudado as práticas
educativas
antigamente a educação funcionava muito
bem como uma receita de bolo porque o
futuro ele era altamente previsível não
tinha tanta transformação
então a gente educar as crianças para
usarem uniformes é todo mundo igual a
todo mundo a gente educada as crianças
pra aprenderem as mesmas coisas no mesmo
tempo e as isso funcionava muito bem
porque elas iam se encaixar
perfeitamente no mercado de trabalho e
se encaixando elas terão a sensação de
estarem adequadas e por isso não se
perguntariam e não se incomodariam com o
fato de estarem realizadas ou não
felizes ou não então antes funcionava
muito bem mas hoje a gente está vivendo
uma era de um futuro tão louco que chega
a ser inimaginável quando a pergunta
assim que você imagina que o seu filho
vai viver o seu filho hoje com quatro
cinco seis anos vai viver no futuro
quando ele tiver seus 30 anos a gente
não consegue nem imaginar e eu diria que
tem pelo menos 65% inimaginável porque
saiu uma pesquisa neste ano de 2018 do
fórum econômico mundial dizendo que 65%
das crianças que entram hoje nas escolas
vão estar trabalhando em profissões que
ainda nem existem
ou seja tem 65 por cento de chance das
crianças que têm hoje entre 4 e 6 anos
não serem nem médico nem advogado nem
engenheiro nem psicólogo
então se a gente não fizer alguma coisa
pra isso mudar logo
pode ser que no futuro elas estejam numa
crise existencial muito maior que essa
que a gente está vivendo hoje
então onde está a origem desse problema
eu comecei a pesquisar isso e comecei
encontrar a origem deste problema numa
época por quatro anos eu trabalhei em
dois ambientes aparentemente distintos e
ao mesmo tempo era assim
de segunda a sexta trabalhava numa
empresa no ambiente corporativo onde
inclusive eu encontrei muitos adultos
infelizes insatisfeitos não realizados e
aos sábados
eu atendia no meu consultório crianças e
ouvia também suas famílias e observar
essas crianças na escola são parentes eu
queria abrir aqui antes de a gente
continuar porque quando eu atendia
crianças eu precisava olhar para as suas
famílias e para as suas escolas é porque
a teoria sistêmica vai dizer que todos
nós nascemos em pontos distintos mas
estamos todos conectados
vivemos um sistema que é interdependente
e aristóteles uma vez falou uma frase
dizem que foi ele que falou né que ele
dizia assim a natureza não faz nada em
vão
eu fico pensando é bem verdade né porque
se existem tantas pessoas é porque cada
uma delas tem algo diferente para
contribuir com esse sistema porque se
fosse pra elas serem iguais e
contribuírem com a mesma coisa
acho que ela natureza teria economizado
energia efeito só um em vez de feito
vários né
e essa percepção também me ajudou a
encontrar a origem deste problema
se você se sente realizado hoje você é
uma pessoa sortuda eu vou dizer porque
ou porque você foi educado para ser você
mesmo e consegue hoje está ocupando
aquele papel que é só seu naquela rede
ou por que você deu uma tremenda sorte
de tendo sido educado com as práticas do
século passado encontrar um lugar
adequado
agora no século 21 mas não aposte nessa
sua sorte para as crianças que a gente
vai educar hoje porque a gente está
vivendo um mundo de transformações
tecnológicas e para viver de modo
automático vai haver uma máquina
que vai fazer isso muito melhor e muito
mais barato que você e aí vai ser como
se a criança que você educa nem
precisasse ter existido nesse sistema
porque funciona mais ou menos assim é
como se a gente nasce uma criança e ao
longo ao lado dessa criança ao redor
dessa criança tivessem várias portas
várias portas que vão indicar caminhos
de ser várias coisas mas só uma porta aí
haguiara para a sua realização para sua
felicidade que só uma porta
a guia para ela ser ela mesma todas as
outras portas ela pode ser várias coisas
- ela mesma e se a gente não fizer
alguma coisa pra mudar logo e agora já
saiu uma pesquisa da organização mundial
da saúde que em 2025 a depressão vai ser
o primeiro problema de saúde que a gente
vai ter então como é que a gente pode
fazer diferente bem a minha proposta é
que a gente passe a educar as crianças
prestando atenção nesses dois pontos
leveza e criatividade o que seria leveza
já percebeu que toda criança nasce leve
ela elas são naturalmente leves e
felizes né
quer ver elas são assim porque elas
estão vivendo a sua própria maneira até
que elas não que elas são condicionadas
a viverem de uma outra forma e aí elas
vão ficando chato e vai chegar aquele
monte de problema inclusive foi olhando
lá para aqueles dois cenários que eu
percebi que havia onde que para o início
daquele problema porque as principais
queixas que eu recebi no meu consultório
como psicóloga adivinham de necessidades
sociais de encaixar as crianças em
padrões e era como se estivesse vendo o
futuro e presente ao mesmo tempo porque
no consultório eu via pais mães escola
fazendo verdadeiros esforços e
investimentos em caixa essas crianças em
padrões e o que eu tava olhando o lado
de cá que eles se tornariam esses
adultos infeliz então leveza é o que
pressupõe que a gente olhe para a
criança com
é ela é e não e não como ela deveria ser
ea gente começa a fazer isso quando a
gente abre mão de expectativas que
expectativa é pensar como ela poderia
ser e não como ela é e aí é muito fácil
a gente pensar né existem vários
parâmetros de desenvolvimento várias
dicas de como a gente deve fazer e aí
por exemplo a criança precisa de saldar
até os 4 anos ela tem que tá andando a 1
aninho se ela fizer alguma dessas coisas
antes do tempo previsto e socialmente é
bonitona é márcio pai a mãe ficou super
orgulhoso né
mas se demorar um pouquinho mais os pais
já começam a ficar nervosos e
preocupados que meu filho tem algum
problema e às vezes já chega até é
pedido da escola de algum possível
diagnóstico vou falar sobre isso daqui a
pouquinho
e aí o que vai acontecendo é que a gente
está o tempo inteiro comparando as
crianças ou para elas serem iguais à
média ou para elas serem melhores mas
raramente com um olhar que olha para a
essência delas que respeita quem elas
são e que respeita o seu próprio tempo
de desenvolvimento
e aí o que acontece é que a vida vai
passando em vez de nós educadores
auxiliar mas e ajudarmos a criança a
chegar mais perto daquela porta da
felicidade
a gente tem feito com que eles fiquem
cada vez mais distantes
então vamos abrir mão das das
expectativas e aqui eu gostaria de falar
um pouquinho sobre os diagnósticos
diagnósticos eles estão se tornando uma
coisa quase que banal de tão comum e
isso tem me preocupado bastante é claro
que com um profissional da saúde eu
entendo que os diagnósticos têm um ponto
super positivo mas esse ponto não está
sendo olhado
o ponto positivo seria por exemplo
quando a gente diagnóstico uma criança
com a pbh autismo dislexia
seria ótimo se essa criança tivesse a
oportunidade de encontrar as melhores
pesquisas com as melhores condições
desse caso
que potencializaram aquele potencial
natural que aquela criança como toda a
outra tem na verdade não é isso que
acontece
o diagnóstico espaço encaixar as
crianças em caixinhas ainda mais rígidas
e afastam elas ainda mais de encontrarem
o seu próprio caminho de desenvolvimento
pleno e de realização
então pra que a gente educa as crianças
com leveza a gente precisa olhar como
elas são entender esse potencial e
auxiliá las a encontrar essa porta
mas pra isso a leveza também vai
pressupor autoconhecimento do adulto só
porque porque o adulto também precisa se
conhecer como ele é ter noção das suas
habilidades das suas dos seus talentos
das suas limitações naturais e até onde
ele dá conta de onde ele não não pode ir
porque a educação é um processo
relacionado ao e ela só vai fluir com
respeito e conduzindo adultos para a
autencidade para a realização se
educador e criança estiverem em sua
essência
então leveza é o que vai permitir com
que a criança abra aquela porta mas
ainda é preciso trilhar vários caminhos
para encontrar a sua realização e isso
não é fácil não existe um caminho em
linha reta então o que a gente vai fazer
pra a pra conseguir trilhar esse caminho
que olhe a minha sugestão é justamente
que a gente possa nutrir a criatividade
dessas crianças mas porque ora porque a
criatividade ela parte da curiosidade já
percebeu que toda criança nasce curiosa
é que a mente dela ainda está vazia de
padrões então ela vai ter
ela tem vontade de conhecer o mundo ela
tá no mundo que ela nunca viu então tudo
pra ela é novidade e tudo pra ela é
extremamente excitante e quando ela
coloca todas aquelas informações pra
dentro da cabecinha dela como ninguém
ainda disse pra ela como ela deve
combinar aquelas informações ela combina
de vários jeitos diferentes ea partir
dessas combinações que surgem as
soluções mais inovadoras e que ela
consegue pensar diferente
então se fosse a gente pensar
fica claro entender que toda criança
nasce pré disposta a agir criativo e o
que a gente precisa é justamente nutriz
e nutrindo também a criatividade a gente
nutre de tabela coragem que concorda
comigo que a criança ou o adulto quando
ele tiver uma idéia super bacana ele vai
precisar de que para colocar essa ideia
em prática para expor essa ideia coragem
então a criatividade é o que vai
permitir com que a criança trilhe o seu
próprio caminho afinal de contas aquele
seu próprio caminho é o único ninguém
passou por ele antes
então você vai precisar de coragem de
todas aquelas habilidades
correlacionadas a criatividade para
poder encontrar e seguir exatamente esse
caminho e tem uma coisa muito legal que
eu percebi na minha clínica com adultos
como arte terapeuta
toda vez que eu resgatava a criatividade
dos adultos de tabela a gente tinha um
certo equilíbrio emocional porque a
criatividade por ser uma habilidade que
permite a gente olhar para as coisas por
diferentes ângulos
a criatividade permitirá que esses
adultos olhassem para os seus pontos
negativos por um olhar mais positivo
então é como se eles conseguissem
equilibrar as coisas que eles tenham
onde eles têm de tão bom com as coisas
que eles têm que são socialmente e nas
seitas e neste equilíbrio eles
conseguiam encontrar um pouco mais de
realização então é também a criatividade
o que vai permitir à criança equilíbrio
mental para trilhar aquele aquele
caminho
então é é como se a leveza abrisse a
porta ea criatividade permitisse a ele
encontrar vários caminhos diferente em
rumo a sua própria realização como a sua
própria felicidade e eu como mãe
desejo muito que os meus filhos sejam
muito felizes no futuro mas mais que
isso
eu desejo que eles encontrem mais
pessoas felizes que eles convivam com
mais pessoas felizes
é por isso que eu estou aqui hoje para
convidar para ser uma peça desse efeito
dominó para ser também um agente de
mudança que transforme a nossa realidade
hoje para que a gente possa viver um
futuro mais harmônico e com mais pessoas
felizes
vamos juntos educar mais crianças com
mais leveza e criatividade
[Aplausos]